en plein cœur des Alpes au-dessus de la
Savoie à quelques kilomètres du
Mont-Blanc ce niche la très chique
station de ski de
Courchevel la station phare des tro
Vallées le plus grand domaine skiable du
monde avec près de 600 km de
piste Courchevel et la seule station
d'Europe à posséder un aéroport
international avec une piste déneigé
toute l'année
donc je prépare l'appareil pour arriver
surchev puis je vais installer
l'appareil dans la finale seul les
pilotes ayant reçu une formation
spécifique peuvent se poser sur cette
piste situé à plus de 2000 m
d'altitude vue d'avion une piste qui a
la taille d'un ticket de métro seulement
500 m de long une pente à
19% forcment ce n pas
dangerv dernier un accident a coûté la
vie à deux
personnes l'altiport de Courchevel
accueille tout l'hiver des skilleurs
venus des quatre coins d'Europe certains
ne viennent ici que pour la journée le
responsable de la tour de contrôle n'est
même plus surpris FPM posé chez nous à
1154 voyez il se parque directement sur
la partie droite ils sortent avec leur
ski ils prennent leur forfait ils vont
au ski ils rentrent dans leur avion et
retourne chez eux le
soir à l'aéroport de Courchevel toute la
journée avion privé et hélicoptèrees se
croisent au rythme des arrivées et des
départs comme cette famille moscovite
adepte de Courchevel depuis plusieurs
années l'hélicoptère il vous emmène il
vous emmène où là pas à Moscou quand
même pas Moscou Mosou Grenoble la Gren
après on prend l'avion c'est quelle
compagnie mon avion
c'est votre avion
[Rires]
privé vous ramen quelques souvenirs de
France l'homme repart avec quelques
magnum de grand cru à bientôt l'anne
[Applaudissements]
prochaine à 100 km de là à rizou dans
les Alpes du Sud les touristes eux aussi
viennent de toute l'Europe mais ils
arrivent en bus ce sont des étudiants
attirés par les tarifs loowost de la
station chaque samedi le parking est
bondé rizou attire chaque année 20000
étudiants avec musique et pack de
bière on peut voir toute la logistique
qu' y a derrière il y a une grosse sono
il y a un petit peu de
liquide ils viennent à rizou pour
s'éclater sur les pistes
mais pas
seulement les sports d'hiver c'est le
joyau du tourisme français chaque année
10 millions de touristes passent leurs
vacances dans nos montagnes en tout 8000
km de piste réparti sur 357 stations de
ski d'une station à l'autre les vacances
au sport d'hiver n'ont pas grandchose à
voir entre
elles à Courchevel la très chiic on peut
tout trouver tout acheter même les ES
des plus grands
artistes c'est ça le charme de
Courchevel c'est pouvoir effectivement
après une journée de ski venir se
balader flanner regarder des très belles
choses nous irons à la rencontre de
Julia une jeune russe venue passer ses
vacances dans un des nombreux palaces de
la station pour profiter de ces pistes
et de ces nuits
sélectes à rizou nous suivrons un groupe
d'étudiants venus décompresser après
leurs examens
entre galère
d'installation V [__] allez devant la
résidence et faites en
diabl au grandâ du gendarme d'ourland
qui va passer sa semaine à tenter de
faire régner l'ordre dans la
station bien souvent ils sont limites
quoi ils arrivent à nous faire des trucs
des nouveaux trucs chaque jour à
Courchevel la nuit aussi a sa face
cachée avec ses prostitué attiré par la
richesse de la
clientèle maintenant je viens avec toi
c'est 500 € mais il y a beaucoup
d'escort girl à Courchevel oui il y en a
beaucoup
Courchevel
rizou de façon très différente de vivre
les sport
d'hiver à rizou les vacances au ski ce
n'est peut-être pas du 5 étoil mais la
petite station des Alpes du Sud a un
gros atout c'est l'une des moins chères
de France
elle attire des étudiants de toute
l'Europe ceux-là viennent de Belgique
ils sont 150 élèves en communication et
ils arrivent enfin après 15h de route
super
fatiguétigué on a la fatigue d'un mois
de blocus dans les pattes plus tout le
trajet de bus et là ça va pas
s'améliorer je crois donc bonjour à tous
bienvenue à
rizou c'est un tour opérator spécialisé
dans les voyages étudiants les Winter
break qui s'occupent de tout 5 he au
niveau duall a de la résidence Les mis
il est où ch t 25 ans et responsable du
BDE de son école le bureau des
étudiants c'est lui qui a choisi rou
pour les vacances mais petit souci leurs
appartements ne sont pas encore prêts et
il faut bien mettre les valises quelque
part heureusement une bagagerie a été
prévue c'est gros
contain il va falloir se changer sur le
parking pour veent pas patienter sans
rien faire jusqu'à ce soir ch des
collants parce qu'il fait
froid des cant pourquoi vous les prenez
maintenant là qu'on change avant parce
qu'on pas encore nos chambres donc 5
qu'on a ce qu' est quand
même cette espè de
cont pour les plus chanceux la bagagerie
fait office de cabine d'essayage quant
aux autres c'est dehors qu'il va falloir
enfiler les combinaisons de
par 15
de
d'AC chaude pour les VoyaG comme ça et
donc comme il y a plusieurs bus qui
arrivent même heure faut libérer la
place et aller plus vite possibleess
faire il n'y a plus de place dans les
containers direction les autres
bagageries installé au cœur de la
station mais c'est à un quart d'heure de
marche c'est horrible franchement c'est
c'est le pire des sacrifices tu mérite
exinaire ouais ben je vois ça après un
mois
d'examen toujours pas mérité
apparemment malgré tous ces petits
désagréments rizou reste depuis 10 ans
la station préféré des étudiants grâce à
ces tarifs
imbattables tu veux pas m'aider à
retrouver ta photo parce que je te
connais pas 349 € la semaine par
personne c'est le prix qui a réussi à
négocier Taric pour le forfait le
transport et l'hébergement 349 € même
pas le prix d'une nuit d'hôtel à
Courchevel si les prix sont aussi bas
c'est que toute une partie du village
est consacrée aux étudiants avec 4000
lit dans des résidences standardisées
alors à rizou pas de chalet individuel
mais des bares d'immeuble des pubs à la
bière pas chè et au menu à tous les
repas c'est sandwich et
tartiflette mais à ce prix-là Taric et
ses amis n'en demandent pas plus
et
suff et cé ambiance on pe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
compter 80 km de piste bordé de
[Musique]
mise c'est peut-être trois fois moins
grand que Courchevel et le domaine des
Trois
Vallées mais largement suffisant pour
s'occuper toute la
semaine ça à l'aise et toi
ouais bah je profite à mort ça fait trop
du bien il fait beau la neige est bonne
les sensations aussi
C mais pas le temps de s'éterniser sur
les
pistes sonop ont une mission de la plus
haute
importanceich l'endroit qui le fera la
bière la MO
[Musique]
chre
oneour pas d'a
bar
néger
ils s'attendent à une négociation serrée
mais le patron des deux barres de nuit
en bas de leur résidence Pierre va les
prendre de vitesses il est là
d'acordch bienenue la clientèle
étudiante c'est son business alors il a
une formule toute prête à leur proposer
une carte de fidélité qui donne droit à
des réductions sur presque toutes les
consommations et qui sert aussi de moyen
de
paiementet payer au bar ça évite en tout
cas de l'argent et quand vous voilà les
tarif avantageux par à ouais là vous
avez un un tarif à ce qu'on appelle à 2
€ vous avez tout ce qui est coca 2 € au
lieu de 3,50 € un tarif qui va au-delà
de leurs espérances mais Taric se méfie
quand même du système de cartte de
fidélité c'est super commercial dans le
sens où tout le monde sait que quand tu
as pas de liquide en poche c'est
toujours plus simple de payer qu'une
carte c'est comme en boîte quand ta
carte de banque c'est toujours plus
facile parce que tu vois pas l'argent
sortir donc ça c'est pas mal aussi vous
AZ possède aussi un snack et il va tout
faire pour que les 150 étudiants
dépensent leur argent chez
lui€ voilà si vous avez des petites
soirées à th tout ça vous voulez venir
déguiser bon voilà il y a pas de souci
vous nous dites vous il va même essayer
de récupérer la soirée qui devait se
dérouler dans un restaurant concurrent
on a un soupé Savo à mon avis m' dit au
Sher je crois comme ça just vous AZ le
faire chez nous si vous voulez je t'avou
vraiment tout c'est vraiment le que
évidemment ça reste bar festif pour le
soir on fait vraiment toute une partie
restauration on fait les Dîn on fait les
barbecue on fait les petits déjeuners a
d'autes idé faire conclu Taric repart
avec tout un lot de carte de fidélité
pour ses camarades même si les étudiants
n'ont pas de gros budget ils ont un
intérêt indéniable ils sont nombreux
économiquement parlant je parle de
volume donc forcément on fait du volume
avec effectivement des des prix plus
plus bas mais au final on s'y retrouve
ça ça fait c'est chix économi
effectivement tari et ses amis viennent
de trouver leur quartier général pour la
semaine les 150 étudiants vont
maintenant pouvoir récupérer leurs
appartements problème ils ne sont pas
très disciplinés
entre ceux qui sont au bar et ceux qui
sont encore sur les pistes tar a bien du
mal à regrouper tout ce petit
monde je peux pas faire une annon
général tout le monde est dispersé je
comprends pas comment ça se fait que
tout le monde est
disperséon va au trucù il y a les bagag
age ensuite vous allez devant la
résidence c'est bon j'aiti j'ai
doucement Taric doit donc répéter 150
fois les mêmes consigne il est
débordé jeer tout le monde moi 8h que
cette jeune fille attend pour
s'installer au
Chud tous les étudiants arrivent en même
temps dans le hall de l'immeuble c'est
la Cohu pour prendre ses clés c'est bon
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
merci l'ascenseur est pris d'assaut
5 étages à monter à
[Applaudissements]
pied pendant une semaine elle va
partager son appartement avec si
[Applaudissements]
copines personnes qui vmir
enas l là ça c'est chiant parce que en a
qui veulent aller dormir plus tard
toutes les chambres sont identiques
petit et Spar superposé dans une chambre
assez petite mais au moins dans celle-ci
il y a une fenêtre là il y en a pas et
mieux vaut bien choisir avec qui on va
passer ses vacances c'est un peu dur
quand on vit à si une semaine de d'être
dans un endroit si étroit parce que
l'année passée je souviens on s'était
engueulé et du coup on se voyait tout le
temps tout le temps et même quand il y
en a une qui était dans une pièce ou
quoi la majorité du temps on se croisait
si bien qu'à la fin c'était
insupportable quoi mais d'un l'utre côté
pour le prix qu'on P je pense que c'est
pas
mal à l'extérieur se déroule un drôle de
Manège le tour opérateur propose des
foot pack des cartons de
nourriture pour 49 € il y a de quoi
tenir une semaine au ski pour une
personne Taric doit en récupérer
quelques-uns un peuenez de l'essous la
formule marche bien auprès des jeunes ce
jour-là plusieurs centaines de footpacks
seront distribués ben oui
pas du fromage la tartincuterie pour le
dîner j'imagine des pommes les fruits
c'est nettement moins cher que de tout
acheter à la supered de la station Tabet
des légumes et ici c'est tout ce qui est
lait faulant matière première oh trop
bien les gâteau oh là les petits pains
oh mon
dieu ou là Taric lui n'en a pas encore
terminé
il est convoqué pour une réunion au
sommet au bar en bas de l'immeuble ce
soir c'est la gendarmerie qui invite et
tar n'est pas tout seul il y a aussi les
responsables des 28 groupes étudiants
présents cette semaine à rizou les
propriétaires des bars des boîtes de
nuit et des résidences chaque année le
maréchal des logis chef d'ourl quitte la
vallée pour passer l'hiver à rizou et
surveiller la station cette réunion
c'est son idée parce qu'il sait très
bien à qui il a affaire bonsoir à tous
merci d'être venu B je me présente je
suis le chef d'ourland je suis du poste
gendarmerie de risou je vais commencer
par tout ce qui est l'alcool à savoir
que l'alcool est interdite sur la voie
publique à résou c'est un arrêté
municipal qui le prévoit on n pas de
boire on pas Dr de se promener avec un
verre on pas de se promener avec une
bouteille sans voix publicque parce que
nous verrons une personne avec ça on lui
fera vider la bouteille directement bien
sûr si vous allez si vous sortez du Spar
pour les ramener chez vous ça compte pas
quoi si vous êtes en train de consommer
pour parler aussi d'une règle qui
interdite en France c'est tout ce qui
est drogue on sait bien
que tout ce qui est hachiche bon et tout
le reste de toute manière mais
parulièrement l'chiche ou l'herbe c'est
interdit nous gendarmes si on voit
quelqu'un avec ne serait qu'un petit
joint il vient chez nous il finit au
poste et il repartira avec son Amand de
vacances quoi et il sera il sera
peut-être pas très content quoi pour
finir vis-à-vis de nous les gendarmes on
les autres aussi hein mais nous
particulièrement euh on a Mar d'entendre
des côescotes des la petite chanson qui
va bien en ce moment là sur je sais plus
de rap là qui est vachement marrante
quoi ça finir au poste tout ça c'est des
outrages c'est simple voilà donc on
finira au poste on a marre de se faire
Fautre de nous comme ça longueur de
journée du respect envers nous voilà ben
je vous remercie d'être venu ce soir
pour pour écouter la sage parole voilà
drôle de pot de bienvenue en plus tar
doit laisser son numéro de téléphone aux
forces de l'ordre en le responsabilisant
les gendarmes espèrent qu'il va jouer
les auxiliaires de police dans son
groupecole de
communication
group moi je personne pour commencer à
faireme T
ma je le dis tu veux fer
[Musique]
tranquilleé éudi lui en font voir de
toutes les
couleurs on d'Ister pas mal sur le fait
qu'alcool on fait des choses pas normal
on a chaud t pasemer le vest vestirou
dans la neige et si personne n là pour
les
ramasser et vous vous en avez pas marre
de voir chaque semaine les mêmes choses
de répéter les mêmes consignes non
chaque semaine c'est NVE TR JIS
par mais ce soirl ce sera plutôt calme
les élèves fatigués par le voyage et le
ski se coucheront tôt mais effectivement
le chef de Roland et ses hommes ne sont
pas au bout de leur
surprise à Courchevel c'est une toute
autre
histoire au lendemain de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale Courchevel sort de
terre si Courchevel n'est pas la
première station française à voir le
jour elle va très vite devenir la
station la plus courue des
ales et c'est en 1975 que la France
entière va la
découvrir et puis bien sûr les vacances
du président de la République arrivé
samedi après-midi à Courchevel pour
goûter la grande solitude des neiges une
solitude à peine troublée par une
soixantaine de journalistes photograph
et caméraman tout juste élu Valérie
giscardestin se laisse filmer sur les
pistes enneigées de Courchevel un coup
de projecteur sur la station savoyarde
et Courchevel est définitivement
célèbre 35 ans plus tard chevel reçoit
jusqu'à 30000 skieurs par semaine ici 80
% des touristes sont
étrangers une clientèle haut de gamme
qui vient y chercher le confort de ses
chalets des chalets qui ont un prix à
Bellecôte le quartier chic de la station
certains valent plus de 50 million
d'euros
Courchevel c'est aussi le luxe de ces
nombreux
palaces avec 12 Hôtels éto ce petit
village de Savo est l'endroit de France
qui compte le plus grand nombre de palac
au m carré de 800 à 20000 € la
nuit le dernier né c'est le Strato un 5
étoil qui appartient à la famille
boisive ancien propriétaire de la marque
de ski
Rossignol pour se démarquer de la
concurrence ils ont misé sur la
restauration en cuisine
qui est au
piano ce grand chef d'origine
pakistanaise est la star montante de la
gastronomie
française les
propriétaires fait entièrement confiance
pour toute la conception de la cuisine
du
restaurant et m'ont donné carte blanche
pour faire exactement ce
[Musique]
queou pour répondre attentes de laentle
de
courchev hésiter à faire venir toute
l'équipe du restaurant 2 étoiles dont il
est le chef léé l'une des meilleures
tables de
France il fait également appel au même
fournisseur aujourd'hui il doit
réceptionner une livraison on va au
moins de les arrivages donc c'est là où
il y a tout sen froide et là on contrôle
la
marchandise le mardi c'est les produits
de la mer tu regarde bien qu'il soit
bien vivant voà
auar bleu et
langoustine ça c'est des belles pièces
c'est des langousines qui font en
général 150 1670 g pièces ça ça a pas de
prix au menu également du bar de ligne
il brille il est beau tu peux le toucher
ils sont bons ça sent très très bon
entre la Bretagne Courchevel c'est pas
trop la distance c'est très rapide
maintenant c'est hyper rapide maintenant
en Bretagne vous avez même des petits
petits fournisseurs qui eux-mêmes font
leur propres camion privé qui partent le
soir de Bretagne après La cri le
lendemain il te livr et là si ça va pas
ça REP et à mon avis il font jamais ces
erreurs là cette année Sylvestre white
s'est fixé un challenge il espère
décrocher deux étoiles pour le
restaurant de Courchevel pour le ski en
revanche il sait qu'il va devoir
attendre encore un peu bon il va être
gentil hein là oui là je peux descendre
ça va les deux ouais là comme ça on fait
je descends pas directement pas
encore avant de venir travailler à
Courchevel Sylvestre W n'avait jamais
mis les pieds à la montagne aujourd'hui
ce n'est que son troisème cours de
[Musique]
ski tu pas en avant pas mettre de tes
skill là c'est comme dans la cuisine si
tu veux être le chef c'est ouais ouais
matriser le couteau tuu devant
entre deux services il a tout juste le
temps de faire quelques
descentes un moment où il peut recharger
les
batteries bien r ça permet de se
dépenser un peu je suis pas du genre
très nerveux en cuisine donc je garde
tout en moi beaucoup de choses en moi le
problème c'est qu'il faut trouver un
moyen d'évacuer le stress et la
fatigue après une heure de détente et de
décompression il est déjà temps pour
white de rejoindre l'hôtel dans moins de
2h il doit être prêt pour le service du
[Musique]
soir d'abord je vais quand même offrir
un un bon vin chaud à Mademoiselle ah la
tradition voilà et après on se rattaque
au travail c'est vous qui le faites le
va non c'est mon chef barman on peut pas
tout faire
hein il est
17h les pistes se vident les rues de
Courchevel elle
s'anime c'est l'heure où il faut se
montrer l'heure où il faut être
[Musique]
vu alors que la nuit tombe le luxe
partout s'affiche fourrure montrre
parure de diamant mais pas
seulement l'pr ski ici ne ressemble à
aucun autre les galeries ont également
leur place Picasso d
warol les œuvres des plus grands
artistes elles aussi sont à vendre à
Courchevel Robert bartou est
propriétaire de nombreuses galeries à
New York à Paris à Cann sa galerie de
Courchevel n'est ouverte que 4 mois dans
l'année c'est pourtant elle qui marche
le
mieux nous avons justement cette
clientèle très élitiste qui qui a une
grosse activité professionnelle
généralement qui a assez pe de temps
dans leur quotidien pour faire des
galeries d'art et qui profitent de ce
séjour à Courchevel où on est un peu en
vascl on est quand on est en vacances
pas la voiture on bouge pas donc on a le
temps de se promener de faire les
galeries justement un amateur d'art
originaire de la Réunion semble être
intéressé par une
[Musique]
œuvre ce crocodile vre de Richard
orlinsk à vendre 35000 €
on ne vient pas ici uniquement pour les
plaisirs de la
glisse c'est ça le charme de Courchevel
c'est pouvoir effectivement après une
journée de ski venir se balader flanner
regarder des très belles
choses moi je suis un grand amateur de
de sculpture et de peinture donc c'est
mon plaisir quand je viens là et
repartir peut-être avec une œuvre
alors ça dépend une
uvreè étoile peut-être voilà la deuxième
étoile l'objetif gagner la deè étoile ça
coûte moins cher cette année on va pour
la deè étole on va s'arranger
hein mais ce soir c'est avec un autre
client que Robert bartou va faire
affaire je vous ai dit he ce que je
faire ce collectionneur suisse a fait
fortune dans l'hôtellerie de luxe et ce
soir il a craqué sur une
sculpture non mais ça je m'en occupe
vous vous inquiétez pas ça ça je joue la
livre détaxé en Suisse
euh une petite remise de 15 % allez
regardez pour vous regardez faites-moi
ça
250000 250000 € et l'affaire est conclue
merci beaucoup à ce prix la livraison
est offerte ça marche on vous prépare on
vous prépare tout ça vous avez craquer
sur quoi
Monsieur il est fier de nous montrer son
acquisition un samouraï en bronze
incrusté
d'émerude ce visage quiire la
sérénité et donc là juste après le
ski c'est la détente
et quelque fois Huse vous savez comme
avait dit un philosophe penseur je sais
pas
il avait
dit quand on aime on ne compte
pas donc là
vouszqu il faut bien de temps en temps
avoir quelques
faiblesse à Courchevel les faiblesses
n'ont pas de
prix à rizou la nuit tout a l'air calme
en apparent
seulement pas un soir sans que le
maréchal des logie chef d'ourl et ses
collègues ne passent une tête dans les
bars histoire que les étudiants
n'oublient pas les règles de la
station mais leur présence n'a pas l'air
de gêner plus que ça les féards
les gars on garde son
t-shirt sur la piste il y en a qui
sortent du lot ce sont les étudiants en
médecine vous faites la fête comme à
Paris ou c'est différent c'est un peu
différent c'est mie
on va d'appartement en appartement on
tout le monde et onê temps ici mais
c'est
[Musique]
génial les problèmes commencent dehors
des jeunes visiblement ivre et à moitié
nu alors qu'il fait Mo- 20
degr et plutôt du genre
bruillant ils ont tous un r
r la
i de
le c'est la sortie voilà les bars ferm
donc ils rentrent tous dans leurs
appartements c'est la période la plus
bruillante de la de la soirée les
gendarmes tentent de calmer le
jeu'il vous plaît bonsir ils sont juste
m
j'ess 2h du matin les bars ferment mais
la soirée est loin d'être finie
les jeunes ont pour habitude de
prolonger la fête jusque dans leurs
appartements les gendarmes le savent
alors chaque soir le chef d'Orland fait
aussi son petit tour dans les
immeubles la résidence possède son
propre service de sécurité mais h
gardien pour surveiller 1500 étudiants
l'exercice se révèle très
compliqué c'est bordel
général c'est bordel général ce soir
c'est plutôt calme mais d'habitude c'est
quand même assez énervé qui j'ai Dr
tiens c'est le bordel ils sont bien bien
souvent bien souvent ils sont nos
limites quoi ils arrivent à nous faire
des trucs des nouveaux trucs chaque jour
hier à 21h05 oui on a les gardiens
notent chaque soir tous les
incidentsou et quand ça va trop
loin gendarmerie signalons des personnes
qui cassent des voitures devant le
bâtimentar trois hommes en état d'
brillé sur le parking ainsi de suite euh
donc ça et puis on continue
aprèsin le locataire chante sur le
balcon la mousse à rasé au niveau 6
grosse fête générale dans le
couloir plusieurs flaes de vomis dans la
cage
d'escalier et ainsi de suite
jusque jusque 4h45 donc on na pas arrêté
jusque 4h45 où ils nous ont cassé toutes
les B et les globes lumineux en sortant
des bar tout ça en une soirée
voil et c'est une main courante à peu
près
norm ce ne sont pas les voisins qui
risquent de se plaindre tous les étages
ont été réservés par des étudiants ils
le savent et ils adorent faire tourner
en Bourque les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gendarmes
camé l'ascenseur ne fonctionne jamais
après minuitin d'éviter tout
c'est à pied qu'il va falloir monter les
étages au 5è les gendarmes surprennent
le début d'une soirée dans les couloirs
des étudiants médecine déjà
bien la responsable du groupe la jeune
femme en blouse blanche ne veut pas de
problème avec les forces de
l'ordre toute est dans ses appartements
sans faire de
vagu pensez qu'il vont rester SAG comme
ça bien sûr ouis je les connais
ah vouloir mettre au lit des jeunes qui
n'ont pas envie de dormir autant dire
mission impossible
ouais j'arrive je je
[Musique]
suis bonsoir
er musi la
musiu la
voix pour
[Musique]
quoi les gendarmes de r party la fête
reprend de plus belles dans les étages
ici c'est le quartier des étudiants
médecine il vient de par
[Musique]
la
journé ils n'ont pas hésité à vider deux
appartements pour les transformer en
boîte de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nuitaine personne s'éclate dans une
chambre d' peine 20 m
car DJ
sono lumière et fumigène ils ont tout
apporté de Paris par le
[Applaudissements]
car en médecine on est plutôt du genre
organisé quand il s'agit de faire la
fête la musique raisonnera dans tous
l'immeuble jusqu'à 4h du
matin les gendarmes n'interviendront
plus ils sont surtout là pour éviter les
gros débordements pas pour verbaliser
sauf quand il tomb sur une grosse
affaire retour à
Courchevel il est 11h30 réy commence sa
journée de
travail depuis 2 jours ce jeune moniteur
de ski est à disposition d'une riche
cliente c'estàdire qu'il a été réservé
pour la semain ex ça va à Courchevel la
majorité des moniteurs travaillent de
cette façon c'est pour cela qu'ici ils
sont si nombreux en tout sur la station
on compte plus de 600 moniteurs là je
pas retrouver mon client ouis à son
hôtel directement c'est du c'est du du
service déjà haut de gamme là c'est un
service le client apprécie c'est plus
confortable pour lui il a pas besoin de
se déplacer ce qui permet de partir plus
vite sur les pistes et on retrouve les
clients à ce moment-là
hôel sa cliente de la semaine réside
dans l'un des plus beaux 5
étoiles au pied des
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pistes ici chaque suite est un chalet
avec son SK
[Musique]
indépendant donc c'est la partie chalet
la partie SK C pour
rentrer peutsi s les SK de
et aller les mettre sur la
piste prêt à
partir un vrai assistant personnel même
si réy s'en
défend qu' on est professeur à à
Courchevel ça fait partie aussi de votre
votre rôle ça notre rôle c'est pas ou
non c'est pas obligatoire disons que
quand je vais skier je vais skier avec
ma femme je lui sors ses ski je prépare
ses ski c'est la galanterie à la
française donc là c'est
pareil galanterie peut-être toujours
est-il que si son client avait été un
homme il aurait dû faire exactement la
même chose cela fait partie de la
prestation tout est prêt ne reste plus
qu'à attendre l'arrivée de la
cliente et parfois cela peut durer de
longues
minutes
réy semble en avoir
l'habitude notre travail c'est d'être là
et d'arriver à l'heure donc après on
attend 20 minutes plus
tard bonjour la cliente de réy arrive
ENF la jeune femme est russe
elle s'appelle
Julia
etéi est décidément très galant c'est
lui qui va lui mettre ses
chaussur les Russes une clientèle
particulièrement
choyée depuis 10 ans ils sont tombés
amoureux de Courchevel au mois de
janvier et au mois de mars la station
vit essentiellement grâce à eux
attention un peu plus à droite VO
ok pour mieux servir cette clientèle
aiséey a pris le russe il y a 5
ans ah vous avez tout oublié il faut
appuyer sur le SK aval aujourd'hui il le
mîtrise
parfaitement comme lui ils sont une
vingtaine de moniteurs à parler le
russe et pour qu'ils se sent encore plus
chez
eux les indications sont même écrites en
cyrilque
[Musique]
dans les ufs Julia tombe sur une de ses
amis elle aussi est avec son moniteur
parulier de Russie jusquici ce n'est pas
que
pour de Mos pouroir
choisev moi je viens ici pour me reposer
mais aussi pour faire la
fête en
discothèque les restaurants sont très
B et accessoirement le ski est super
iciy je mais après 2 he de ski Julia
veut déjà s'arrêter pour retrouver ses
amis dans un des restaurants d'altitude
les plus chics de
[Musique]
courchevelbè Julia ne Seira plus de la
journée journ pas trop éprouvante
aujourd'hui différent des autres une
journée plutôt cool aujourd'hui voilà on
a des journées cool comme ça puis on a
des journées on vaqu 7h aujourd'hui ça
fait partie des journées cool et vous
êtes payé le même tarif que ce soit pour
7h ou pour 2h de ski vous le client
réserve un moniteur pour la journée donc
il paye le même tarif à l'école de ski
il payer son son tarif
journée une journée facturée 360 € pour
seulement 2 heures de travail quand les
Russes sont là c'est toute la station
qui fait des affaires dans certains
restaurants d'altitude ce sont les seuls
à se payer des grands crus certaines
bouteilles comme ce Pétrus sont vendu
plus de 30000
€. il y a 4 ans pourtant les Russes ont
failli tourner le dos définitivement à
Courchevel une affaire de prostitution a
jeté une ombre cette semaine sur la
station très prisée de Courchevel 25
personnes ont été arrêtées dans le
milliardaire russe patron de la première
compagnie minière Michel prokorov l'une
des plus grosses fortunes mondiales est
alors soupçonné dans une affaire de
proxénétisme finalement relâché faute de
preuve l'homme proche de Poutine va
jusqu'à demander des excuses à l'état
français dans un communiqué le
milliardaire déclare ni moi ni mes amis
ne prévoyons de revenir en France
jusqu'à ce que l'affaire soit classée et
que des excuses en règle ai été
formulé les Russes vont àors Bou chevel
entraînant un gros manque à gagner pour
la station mais en décembre 2009 lors
d'une rencontre France-Russie entre
François Fillon et Vladimir Poutine le
milliardaire russe présent à cette
occasion obtiendra ce qu'il avait exigé
la presse française n'en fera pas écho
c'est le Times qui va le révéler
quelques semaines plus tard la France a
finalement présenté ses excuses au
milliard Michel prorov dans l'affaire de
proxtisme depuis prorov Russ sont
revenus à Courchevel et le Noël russe de
cette année organisé par la station a
été un
succès champ
orthodoxe descente au flambau par les
moniteurs de l'école de
ski et feu
d'artifice les Russes ont retrouvé le
sourire et dépensent à nouveau sans
compter à eux seul ils représentent près
de la moitié du chiffre d'affaires de la
[Applaudissements]
station alors désormais plus question de
venir les déranger dans les lieux où ils
font la
fête lors de notre venue à Courchevel en
pleine période russe nous n'avons pas
été autorisé à filmer à
l'intérieur un saisonnier qui travaille
dans l'un de ses établissements a
accepté de nous
parler de peur de perdre son emploi il
nous parle visage caché à l'entendre on
comprend mieux pourquoi nous n'avons pas
été autorisés à filmer comment ça se
passe pendant la période des Russes
c'est l'excès il ils peuvent commander
toutes sortes de choses et pas les
manger les gros russes qui s'allument un
grand cigare en plein milieu d'une salle
pleine non fumeur et tout demande un
cendrier et quand tu dis que c'est non
fumeur il peut te filer un billet de 500
€ et tu lui apporte un cendrier il paye
tout le monde il paye le il paye le
personnel en pourbois
il il ils amèent du bon chiffre au
patron en en dépense du coup tout le
monde tout le monde est content mais ce
n'est pas tout il nous confie également
que la prostitution est très présente
même si elle se veut discrète à force de
d'être au même endroit et de voir les
mêmes filles tous les jours que on peut
se dire que c'est des filles qui
travaillent elles vont venir à une table
et consommer le strict minimum et qui se
font finalement inviter donc elles
changent de table elles vont sur la
table du du client et après elle reste à
cette table là se fait payer le repas et
après repart avec donc c'est et après le
lendemain quand tu vois la même fille
revenir et qui aprèsp avec un autre gros
client qui c'est un
peu c'est grillé quoi il y a vraiment
une recissance de prostitué dans la
période des Russes oui la prostitution
on la retrouve partout à Courchevel dans
les boîtes dans les bars et elles sont
attirées par les Russes qui sont en
vacances ça flambe à droite à gauche et
c'est vrai que c'est
c'est facile pour le vérifier nous nous
rendons en caméra cachée dans ces
endroits branchés des nuits de
[Musique]
Courchevel à peine le temps de faire le
tour que nous sommes
abordés vous allez
où qu'est-ce que vous voulez moi je suis
là je fais un tour maintenant je viens
avec
toi c'est 500
€ vous êtes vraiment direct oui allez on
y va nous décidons de nous rendre dans
une autre boîte de nuit juste avant d'y
arriver nous sommes de nouveau à costé
cette fois en pleine rue bonsoir bonsoir
Comment ça va bien quel est votre nom
moi c'est Roxan je viens de Moscou de
Moscou oui peut-être que vous voulez un
peu de compagnie dans ma chambre des
massages du sexe beaucoup de
plaisir des massages du sexeoup plisir
c'est 500
€ autre endroit autre
ambiance mais ici le prix est plus
[Musique]
élevé et le prix c'est
combien le prix c'est 800
€ si la majorité des escort girl sont de
l'Est et accompagne les riches clients
venus séjourner à
Courchevel d'autres se logent dans des
chambres beaucoup moins luxueuses et
profitent des largesses de la riche
clientèle elles sont présentes à
Courchevel le temps de la période russe
pour en savoir plus nous avons suivi
l'une de ses escort girl jusque dans sa
chambre elle vient de
Cuba mais il y a beaucoup d'escort girl
à Courchevel oui il y en a beaucoup
pourquoi ben parce que il y a beaucoup
de Russes elles savent très bien qu'avec
eux elles peuvent gagner beaucoup
d'argent avec les rus c'est 1000 100 ou
€ en période russe tout le monde gagne à
Courchevel à rizou le travail du chef
d'ourlan ne s'arrête pas aux nuits agité
de la station ce matin-là les étudiants
sont déjà sur les
pistes les gendarmes chosent eux aussi
leur
ski bonjour bonjour C'est déguisement là
c'est bon non c'est normal ça la flashi
là ça flash sur les sur les
P même sur la neige le chef d'ourl veut
les avoir à
l'œil on fait une surveillanceain
skillable on recherche les les éventuels
comportements
dangereux qui pour qui pourrait découler
de problèmes d'alcool souvent de
ou de drogue aussi si vous chopez
quelqu'un en train de boire ou de fumer
un joint sur les pistes qu'est-ce qui se
passe ben si c'est de la drogue il a
grand Chan qu'il finisse avec nous au
poste hein tout le monde sait que g en
France après l'alcool ça va dépendre de
l'état de la personne on pe même
demander au pisteurs éventuellement de
venir de nous le descendre si on trouve
qu'il est trop S pour descendre tout
seul
et déjà pour lui pour le protéger lui
puis pour protéger les autres usagers
des
pistes un peu de maintien de l'ordre sur
les pistes voilà qui n'est pas pour
déplaire au chef
d'ourl ce n'est pas le cas dans toutes
les stations de sport d'hiver mais les
gendarmes de rizou sont de très bons
skieurs
[Musique]
depuis 4 saisons qu'il offici rou il a
repéré les coins préférés des fumeurs de
joint au détour d'une piste derrière un
arbreour un petit groupe isolé attire
son attention
ok
vous avez fini de fumer là ce monsieur
il a dans la main il a son m là je vois
pas qu'il se brûle
ouvre la main pourir un petit
joint ou contrôle
d'identité les TR jeunes gens viennent
de belgique merci vous avez encore des
voir
vre la matière est
où produit produit stupéfiant vous avez
pas donc si on vous fouille on trouve
rien vous êtes sûr donc vous avez fait
juste un joint vous êtes venu juste avec
un joint de chez vous j'ai
encoreint ouais ben voilà on va déjà les
prendre c'est leur premières vacan à
risou ils vont s'en
souvenir voulez rouler le soir avant de
partir mettez dedans donnez-moi la boîte
mettez
dedans vous savez qu'en France interdit
la
drogue vous savez
pas pas plus que ça
vous allez venir avec nous on va aller
au poste de gendarmerie en
bas ah ouais je vous laisse chausser
prendre vos sacs et on se suit avec la
saisie de leur joint il pensait la faire
terminé en Belgique la législation est
plus tolérante en la
matière mais en France c'est un
dél et le chef d'Orland en a plus casser
des fumeurs de mariruana sur les
pistes le petit groupe est escorté
jusqu'à la station direction le poste de
gendarmerie la prise va se révéler
beaucoup plus fructueuse que
prévu l' vient de chez vous de
Belgique avec
vous l'herbe la vi de chez de Belgique
ouz encore
l'appartement on chercher
alors dans le cadre d'un flagrantlit les
gendarmes n pas besoin de mandat de
perquisition pour aller fouiller leur
appartement là surprise l'appartement
n'est pas
vide bonjour ça tombe bien on pouir
faire le 4e avec
OK national vous nous avez reconnu vous
parlez français monsieur ou ou vous n
avez reconnu c'est la
gendarmerie donc on a attrapé au petit
camarad sur les pistes en TR de fumer un
joint pour leurs copains le réveil est
brutal qu'estce que vous faisiez vous là
est pris le joint dans le
cendrier c'est dommage mauvais
moment vous avez une pisantité oui s'il
vous
plaît
Valis les gendarmes n'ont pas à chercher
bien loin les stupéfiants sont encore
dans les valises ça c'est
Monsieur avezvous du
produit les quatre amis ont tous une
petite réserve pour la semaine quatre
gros sachets de marirana et un bon bloc
de résine de
cannabis on est arrivé samedi
matin juste le début des vacances c'est
juste le début ouais tout
début pu voilà des vacances de ski son B
c'est plus vraiment des vacances de ski
fa connaî donc voilà
quoi prochaine on reprendra avec ça
c'est sûr il y a quelque chose qui
intrigue le chef d'Orland c'est quoi ça
la matière blanche là du sel c'est pour
cuisiner comme ça on do pas prendre du
sel alors il y a lesb le sel et le
poivre c'est ça ouais il av une astuce
là-dessus peti astuce c'est la première
fois qu'il voit ça une petite astuce à
mon avis c'est pour ça c'est pour
essayer de tromper les toutous passage à
la Douine ouis je c'est psychologique
ouais c'est psychologique on se dit
tiens peut-être que ça fera quelque
chose quoi donc vous saviez très bien
qu'enf comp vous avez pas le droit
d'amener de la drogue en France pas
comme tout à l'heure vous saviez pas on
est d'accord
est pas bte il faut toujours se méfier
des questions faussement naïv du chef
d'Orland
bel c'est pas mal quand
Mme pourir quelle quantité de produit
stupéfiant été sais le gendarme va chez
un commerçant du coin
vous êtes obligé de venir à la pharmacie
pour faire ça vous avez pas une balance
non pas fourni donc le BR c'est
arrangeant la balance n'est pas
franchement réglementaire mais c'est
juste pour savoir quelle suite
judiciaire donner à
l'affaire un petit peu moins de 100 g en
tout je pense que ça doit quand même
avoir une petite valeur surtout pour
moins de 50 g par personne les quatre
Belges ont droit à une procédure
simplifiée pas de garde à vue les
auditions vont se faire sur le champ ils
écoperont d'une amende de 100 € par
personne et ils seront fichés par les
douanes pour les 3 ans à
venir ils seront relâchés dans quelques
heures et termineront leurs vacances
tranquillement mais après une histoire
pareille pas sûr qu'on les retrouve sur
les pistes de rizou l'année
[Musique]
prochaine